I've been trying to figure out when to
plant seeds no matter how I count the
days it's still too early we're only at
February 5th right now our last frost is
May 15th it's still a little bit too
early to keep things inside so mini
Greenhouse macro Greenhouse both are
great ways to plant seeds winter sewing
is a great way to grow flowers for your
summer garden and it's fast and easy and
something to do in the winter time
winter sewing seeds is basically
providing the ideal conditions for the
seeds to
when they are ready I find that's often
the hardest part about planting seeds
indoors in the spring from when you
plant it how many days does it take to
germinate and then how many days should
it grow in a pot before you put it
outside how long do you have to huren it
off for but if I plant things outside
basically I don't have to worry about
the timing so winter sewing mimics what
happens in nature which is always the
best approach for our Gardens we're
going to prepare some containers for
winter sewing a lot of people use milk
jugs that seems to be the most popular
popular thing that I see I'm using what
I have around and I have these
containers that we got pears and peaches
in this summer so they're great because
they're clear plastic you want something
that's either clear or translucent that
can let the light in I'm going to fill
it up with a little bit of soil so
you're going to sprinkle the seeds on
the top and you're going to put just a
little bit of soil on top and Tamp it
down we're going to close the lid and
we're going to label it so we remember
what we planted in here and then we're
going to put this outside so it's going
to go outside into a sunny location
that's going to get some rain that isn't
sheltered but that isn't right out in
the open in the middle of your yard you
don't want it anywhere that's going to
blow away so what we're doing when we
make these little mini green houses is
similar to what happens in this
greenhouse even though they're exposed
to the elements so when it gets cold it
will get cold it gets as cold on our
maximan thermometer I can see as minus
10 Celsius in this greenhouse that would
probably be in the middle of the night
during a cold night with no sun but then
during the day when it heats up when the
sun coming in I can see it's been as
high as 30 degrees Celsius in here on a
sunny day so the same thing is going to
happen in this small container also
important is the small container has
holes in the bottom where it's going to
be able to drain water the same as this
drains water just into the ground and it
has holes in the top what this does is
it protects as well from the elements so
the ground here and in here is protected
from this snowfall so there's not ice on
the surface where the seeds would have a
hard time breaking through there's not
wind drying out the seedlings or drying
out the seeds or moving the seeds around
they're in a protected environment
that's going to allow them to germinate
a little bit better so this technique
works really well for a lot of plants
but it works well especially for plants
that need cold and moist stratification
plants will wait until they've had a
cold period before they germinate this
is mimicking our natural Seasons you've
got a wet Autumn period then you've got
a cold winter and then you have spring
where the temperatures are starting to
warm up you don't need to harden these
plants off so they're already germinated
outside growing outside you may need to
just let them adjust to the wind a
little bit but other than that they
should be pretty hearty and strong
compared to a Seedling that you grew in
the house and ured under lights some
perennial seeds that you may be growing
uh are plants that are native to our
area like milkweed Ando Joie weed Lupin
colines also things like eonia some
herbs as well ch I'm going to do some
winter savory some time it works to do a
lot of the sort of Summer annual flowers
it's an easy way to grow a lot of them
things like zenas am hiip bachelor
buttons alysum pangula these are seeds
that often will self seen in my garden
but I'm going to grow them just in a
more controlled environment here and
then I can sort of determine where they
should go in a better way so here we are
in our unheated Greenhouse even though
we just got a big dump of snow you can
see there's snow on the roof snow on the
sides I just had to shovel a path to to
the door the ground in here is still
obviously not covered with snow There's
an opportunity to actually plant seeds
what we're doing here is we're just
going to plant them in the ground right
now and then they're going to germinate
when they're ready I don't have to worry
about how long it takes them to
germinate I don't have to worry about
what temperature they're at I don't have
to worry about hardening them off I'm
just going to put them in the ground and
see what happens it's been quite quite
cold lately I just want a little layer
of Extra Protection here so I'm going to
fill in the rose with spinach seed seeds
where it didn't quite come up as much as
I would have liked it to and I can see
there's three rows here and here I'm
just planting it right in between where
the seeds are so even though the spinach
is very small right now I'm always
amazed at how fast it grows once it gets
going once the days get longer the
temperatures get warmer it really really
takes off fast so it goes from having
just like two little leaves it's got its
calans and its first set leaves it
second set of leaves are just starting
it'll like double in size in a week as
soon as it starts growing spinach really
likes the cold weather having it out
like this is ideal for it it'll actually
grow better I find in a greenhouse like
this in March than it will out in the
garden once the weather gets warm it
stops growing as
quickly